man geht viel bewusstsein in den tag
hinein wenn man ein gedicht gelesen hat
sogar wenn es das von philipp ist ich
wollte mit philipp immer mal über lyrik
sprechen aber er hat sich immer
verweigert das gesagt ich lass mich mit
lyrik in frieden motto man noch machen
kannst ich habe das gefühl ich schon den
spiegel
es gibt ja experimentelle lyrik und dann
gibt es auch eine art von klassischer
lyrik würde ich sagen mit der ich
vielleicht apriori ein bisschen mehr
anfangen kann sowieso mit klassischen
texten mehr anfangen als mit modernen
texten habe ich auch gedacht ich bin
doch total offen für neues mascha kaléko
ich weiß nicht kennst du die natürlich
nicht irgendwie gehört nicht zum kam und
der klassiker deswegen kenne ich sie
nicht mein schönstes gedicht ich schrieb
es nicht aus tiefsten tiefen stieg essig
schmieg es ja das gefällt mir
also erstens weil das zu dir passt und
22 lässt den gedanken variiert die nicht
auch immer schon faszinierend fand
nämlich es gibt auch auf diesen satz ist
die besten romane nie geschrieben worden
sind je mehr man sich beschäftigt mit
literatur desto mehr entdeckt man die
tiefe weisheit hinter solchen sätzen
ich habe noch was ich habe noch ich
hatte es befürchtet es soll ja autoren
leben
die dichten und noch soll die reihen
gedicht gedichtet haben und zu denen
gehört philipp tingler ob ibra mol ohne
op wohl fühle ich mich nicht wohl ohne
modul hilft mir weihnachten nicht viel
das gedicht das ist kein buch jetzt muss
ich wieder damit fertig werden dass ich
hier diesen hawker und muss irgendwie
damit zurechtkommt das ist ein kleiner
ausgelegt haben wohl und möchte jetzt
viel zu weit also ich habe meinen sohn
und links lernen mitgebracht es ist von
heinrich heine das glück ist eine
leichte deren und weilt nicht gern am
selben ort sie streicht das hd von der
stirne und küsst ich rasch und flattert
fords frau unglück hat im gegenteil ich
liebe fest ans herz gedrückt sie sagt
sie habe keine eile
setzt sich zu dir ans bett und strickt
sehr schön ist es nicht wunderbar völlig
nüchtern wie einige oft und auch
geradezu von umwerfender leichtigkeit
und es hat diesen gedanken dass man
bitte immer noch selbst auch
verantwortlich ist für sein glück in dem
er dieses bild benutzt von der leichten
dirne sagt er uns auch es ist richtig so
dass das vorübergehend ist weil man
sonst das glück gar nicht empfinden
könnte also deine interpretation das
verstehe ich ist nachvollziehbar aber
ich hätte das wahrscheinlich anders
gelesen vielleicht ein bisschen
pessimistischer ist es jetzt darstellt
wir machen gerade diesen prozess durch
nicola wo du als durch an durch
miesepetriger charakter her die negative
seite erkennt in diesem gedicht und ich
als hoffnungsfroher immer vorwärts gehen
oder mensch das optimistische see und
das ist genau das was doch lyrik wenn
sie gut ist ausreichend
[Musik]